[Musique]
troisième invité politique c'est ronan
dantec bonjour bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nos sénateurs écologistes de
la loire atlantique et pascal jalabert
pour la pqr qui est toujours avec nous
du groupe ebra alors on entend à
bordeaux un des conquêtes pour les
écologistes est ce que ce matin vous
nous affirmer que les écologistes auront
bien un groupe est composé de combien de
sénateur eh ben le nombre final je ne le
connais pas je pense que ce matin on est
à une douzaine je pense qu'ils ont
encore d'autres sénateurs qui se posent
des questions donc je dirais le minimum
c'est 12 et ça sera peut-être plus dans
les prochaines heures de quelles
tendances qui se pose des questions on
va écouter il ya des sénateurs divers
gauche il y à des sénateurs d'un certain
nombre de territoires qui sont
effectivement très régionaliste
donc qu'est-ce que cet international
installé en haute corse
vous affirmez qu'il allait rejoindre
groupe par exemple affirmé il faudrait
lui demander mais je vous rappelle que
entre europe ecologie les verts et
régions et peuples solidaires
il y a généralement des désaccords au
moment des élections européennes
françois alfonsi et député européen
corse sur les élus sur la liste
écologiste dans quelle logique politique
à ce qu'ils nous rejoignent
mais on en discutera n'a effectivement
rien il y a un groupe écologiste ce
groupe écologiste un socle ce matin aux
alentours d'une douzaine mais il a
encore des des possibilités d'être plus
important combien coûte labeaume en
demander beaucoup mais j'imagine que
vous avez réfléchi depuis hier je pense
que oui mais enfin attendez il faut
quand même discuté avec avec les
sénateurs qui arrive je pense
qu'effectivement il ya une perspective
vers la quinzaine qui est qui est
ouverte ce matin vous êtes candidat
présider ce groupe même écouter un petit
groupe
je m'attendais un peu à la question un
petit gros c'est un consensus
ça c'est absolument essentiel mois chez
l'expérience évidemment du premier
groupe écologiste on était dix c'était
jean vincent placé jean vincent placé
qui le présidait
c'est des groupes qui sont toujours des
groupes délicat à manier
parce qu'effectivement c'est toujours
des fortes personnalités et une dizaine
surtout celle effective et non pas
spécialement
je crois que tous les sénateurs des
fortes personnalités donc la recherche
du consensus dans la gouvernance du
groupe c'est la priorité
si on commence à jouer à qui est
candidat et qui se déclare candidat
c'est pas comme ça qu'il faut faire ça
par semaine fait pas mystère du fait
qu'elle ait envie de cette geôle et
honte au président est ce parce que vous
aussi vous vous dites voilà moi aussi
j'ai envie de présider ce groupe
non non moi je dis on va se réunir
demain matin et on trouvera un consensus
de gouvernance et entre nous mais pour
qu'un consensus il faut qu'il y ait des
gens qui aient envie de présider ce
groupe est ce que vous en faites partie
des gens que je pense que des gens qui
ont nom lui il y en a encore d'autres
d'eau que si vous me permettez je n'en
resterai là dessus en disant nous devons
rechercher le consensus
évidemment ça va un petit peu agité le
landerneau politique ce matin de savoir
qui sera le président ou la présidente
de ce groupe mais moi ce qui m'importe
c'est sa cohérence et sa solidarité dans
la durée pour ça effectivement il faut
trouver un consensus
comment discute demain matin on va voir
sur notre animation l'hémicycle avec
la création de votre groupe et d'une
douzaine de sénateurs un dernier mot sur
ce groupe
est ce que vous savez déjà quel nom il
portera puisqu'on entend dès hier des
élus dire il faut que ça aille au delà
d'europe écologie les verts il faut que
ça soit plus large
ce groupe sera plus lorsque europe
ecologie les verts par définition
puisqu'il ya sept sénateurs europe
écologie les verts sur 12 donc par
définition il ya un peu deux piliers un
pilier europe écologie verts un pilier
on va dire divers écologistes et
régionalistes
donc il faut trouver un nom qui
correspondent à tout cela mais ça je
suis pas très inquiet sur ce point alors
vous avez parlé consensus médian aussi
le mot union on a vu à bordeaux à
marseille que quand la gauche s'est uni
avec les écologistes ça fonctionnait en
revanche il ya des endroits et bien ou
le fait de vous divisez vous avez perdu
potentiellement des sièges c'est une
leçon à retenir notamment en vue des
prochaines échéances
ah ben moi ça me semble tout à fait
évident on a fait un calcul rapide hier
soir les écologistes et la gauche ont
perdu par des unions entre 10 et 12
sièges
ce matin s'il y avait une dynamique
d'union
1 nous saurions absolument pas avec la
même analyse la droite serait en baisse
significative et tous les groupes
écologistes socialistes et communistes
serait en hausse qu'est ce qui s'est
passé moi je préside un mouvement de
rassemblement qui s'appelle en somme sur
nos territoires qui prenait à la fois la
transition écologique et sociale et le
rassemblement de l'ensemble des
écologistes et des forces de gauche qui
sont d'accord clairement d'accord sur
cette transition écologique et sociale
moi je ne suis pas sûr que dans tous les
départements
le parti socialiste qui est divers avec
des cultures départementale aujourd'hui
extrêmement diverses chercher cette
dynamique je vais prendre un exemple du
finistère que je connais bien
j'en suis natif dans le finistère le
parti socialiste a proposé à ses
partenaires la quatrième place en
prenant pour lui les trois premières
places et c'était non discutable
résultat des courses le parti socialiste
perd même le deuxième siège
alors que s'il avait proposé le
troisième probablement qu'il y aurait un
accord et y aurait aujourd'hui trois
sénateurs
en or le finistère deux socialistes un
écologiste c'est un exemple typique de
ce qui s'est passé
donc est-ce que le message va être
entendu cette fois ci plus que les fois
précédentes je n'en sais rien je pense
que je rejoins patrick kanner sur un
point je rejoins pas sur tous les points
mais je rejoins sur un point et je crois
que ça va être aussi la responsabilité
du groupe écologiste qui est que nous
avons maintenant besoin de travailler
sur un projet sur un projet clair les
écologistes aussi ont besoin de
travailler c'est à dire que les
écologistes aujourd'hui devienne un
parti de gouvernement en capacité
électorale à gérer de grandes
collectivités est en capacité demain
peut-être de gagner la présidentielle
ça veut dire qu'on a un projet à deux
gouvernements qui est aussi un projet
clair donc il va falloir travailler et
les moyens du groupe écologique vont
servir aussi à travailler sur sur le
fond il pour finir là-dessus
il faut aussi qu'on sache où en sont nos
partenaires est-ce qu'il ya encore des
socialistes pro nucléaire puisque la
sortie du nucléaire fait quand même
partie des choses aujourd'hui absolument
incontournable dans un projet de
reconquête par la gauche et les
écologistes
voilà ce genre de questions il faut pas
revenir sur cette vision un peu plus
nationale mais d'abord au sénat puisque
vous nous parler d'union patrick kanner
n'avez que ce mot à la bouche vous
n'avez que ce mot à la bouche pourquoi
versés qu'à créer votre propre groupe et
pourquoi ne pas faire un grand groupe
socialistes et écologistes voire
communiste
non mais je pense qu'on est quand même
dans un moment de 2e ou le débat
démocratique doit être fait et le sénat
est organisé comme ça avec les
sensibilités qui s'expriment
je pense qu'il y avait surtout une
bizarrerie démocratique dans le fait que
les écologistes baisse beaucoup dans la
société française n'était pas représenté
au sénat
donc incapacité y compris d'initiative
parlementaire parce que notre métier
c'est quand même de produire de la loi
donc difficultés pour produire des
amendements pour produire d'émissions
d'information des commissions d enquête
et être présent dans le dans le débat
donc démocratiquement c'est tout à fait
évident qu'il fallait un groupe
écologiste et il y aura un groupe
écologiste
après ces différents groupes de gauche
moi moi je suis favorable à l'union je
pense qu'elle est nécessaire à la
reconquête du pouvoir
mais cette union doit se faire avec
justement des groupes qui dialoguent sur
le fond on est dans un moment où il faut
travailler sur le fond la question c'est
pas le mercato de savoir si on va finir
à 12 ou 15 ou si le socialisons perdre 3
ou 5 sièges
la question c'est est-ce que sur le fond
il ya vraiment des accords parce que des
accords y en a stéphane le foll dans
ouest france
effectivement son interview est assez
violente
je crois que le terme correspond y
compris vis-à-vis de maires socialistes
qui ont passé des accords avec des
écologistes où il remet en cause leur
position sur la 5g ce qui est quand même
incroyable
je rappelle que sur la 5g a priori si
nous sommes contre c'est parce que c'est
un investissement qui ira toujours sur
les mêmes territoires alors que dans le
centre bretagne
l'autre jour je ne pouvais pas envoyer
de texto et que c'est donc un d'abord un
débat d'aménagement du territoire
et heureusement que la gauche remet en
cause la question de la 5g heureusement
que des maires de gauche comme journal
reno en atelier à paris le fond mais
toute la mère de noisetier à ses côtés
un curseur pendant les municipales vous
aurez secondes sa liste est ce que vous
dites aujourd'hui l'avenir des
écologistes c'est avec le parti
socialiste
et est ce que l'avenir du parti
sociétaires et écologistes je pense
qu'effectivement nous sommes dans ce
moment d'une nécessité de clarification
tout le parti socialiste ne s'engage pas
sur la transition écologique et sociale
ça c'est très clair
aussi aujourd'hui donc je pense qu'il va
y avoir des débats aussi internes au
parti socialiste mais fication
évidemment évidemment que ce moment est
nécessaire et va être compliqué on le
voit bien dans les prises de position
mais je suis pas là d'abord pour
commenter la situation de fortis et je
pense que chez les écologistes aussi
nous sommes dans un moment et le groupe
écologiste au sénat va avoir un rôle
très important à ce niveau là dans un
moment d'approfondissement du projet
avec avec des des propositions suivant
les tendances des soutes en danse de la
famille écologiste qui sont pas
exactement les mêmes où il va falloir
aller au fond dix ans demain nous
revendiquons le pouvoir qu'est ce que
nous en ferons
quelles sont les étapes de la transition
clairement pour
écologie ça va être les écologistes au
sénat ça va être un laboratoire de ce
que peuvent être les écologistes si un
jour il arrive au pouvoir
moi je crois et je crois profondément à
ça et je croit notamment que la les
moyens que donne le sénat vous ça va
être aussi l'occasion de dialoguer plus
profondément avec la société avec des
territoires moi je note quand même ça
n'a pas été dit je pense l'exemple de la
vienne où j'étais allé soutenir les les
candidats écologistes ils font 20 % des
voix il faisait 5
la fois précédente là ils font 20 ils
n'ont pas d'élus milf ont 20% s'ils font
20 % porté le nom maintenant ça suffit
pas c'est parce qu'ils ont eu énormément
de voix en milieu rural je rappelle par
exemple sûr il y a trois ans moi je suis
élu principalement par la grande
majorité des élus divers gauche ruraux
qui se retrouvent dans l'offre politique
comporte alors que j'ai quand même une
étiquette écolo très forte donc ces
mutations là sont intéressantes ce qui
veut dire que senna
les écologistes vont avoir aussi un
projet pour la ruralité pour le
réaménagement du territoire a porté de
manière extrêmement précise également
que concrètement ça veut dire qu'il faut
puisque d'autres échéances arrivent très
vite 99 projets départementaux 18
projets régionaux et un projet
présidentiel comme un bas je pense qu'à
pas besoin de 99 projets départementaux
les compétences sont les mains d'un
département alors oui il ya évidemment
des spécificités défense avec des
accords politiques qui vont avec
moi je crois qu'il faut être clair
aujourd'hui pour les régionales un os ne
va pas vers l'union au premier tour mais
il ya une grande différence par rapport
au sénat c'est qu'un deuxième tour c'est
là c'est une proportionnelle à un tour
donc là la prime à la désunion elle est
évident pour pertes servir de primaire
moi je le pense c'est l'hiver je pense
qu'effectivement on va plutôt vers cela
de ce que je vois
mais surtout il faut prendre il faudra
préparer des dynamique de rassemblement
ce qui veut dire aussi des socialistes
aujourd'hui même des socialistes qui ont
le pouvoir dans des régions qui sont
capables de dire si les écologistes sont
devant j'irai avec les écologistes
même si je suis le président sortant ça
je ne l'entends pas beaucoup j'entends
beaucoup des présidents socialistes
qu'ils disent
venez avec moi au deuxième tour mais
j'entends pas les présidents socialistes
sortants dire clairement et
1 comme nous voulons l'union si je suis
derrière j'irai avec le candidat
écologiste en tête de liste c'est aussi
ces clarifications là qu'on doit avoir
dans un certain nombre de départements
mais j'entends que moins dans le nord 1
patrick kanner a ouvert sur une
candidature de rassemblement qui
pourrait être effectivement un
écologiste en tête de liste c'est à dire
notamment avec damien carême juste un
mot sur le fond puisque vous nous dites
que le groupe écologiste à être un
laboratoire de ce que pourraient être
les écologistes c'est aller au
gouvernement vous allez créer votre
groupe ça va être quoi la priorité sur
le fond sur quels sujets vous allez
commencer à vous engager
voilà je pense que par définition on va
avoir des sénateurs avec des priorités
différentes suivant leur commission il
me semble quand même que l'agenda climat
des prochaines semaines est très
important il ya 30 milliards sur la
table pour la transition écologique je
veux quand même vérifier où vont ces 30
milliards il ya effectivement l'a dit
que les oui j'ai quand même encore en
encore des doutes parce que si on met
400 à 500 millions sur le nucléaire je
suis pas sûr qu'on les mette sur la
transition
j'ai l'impression qu'on les remette dans
les sables du désert mais surtout il me
semble que nous avons les propositions
de la convention citoyenne sur le climat
le président de la république a dit
qu'il allait les appliquer on voit déjà
que pour air france l'écotaxe là aussi
ça rétropédale de tous les côtés on voit
que beaucoup de propositions au delà
d'un discours général du président de la
république sont rodés tricoté par les
ministères les cabinets et la
technostructure donc nous on va avoir un
combat très très fort très important
dans les prochains mois à la fois aux
lois de finances et puis sur la loi
climat qui doit arriver en début d'année
donc il faut travailler travailler tout
de suite pour vérifier que le contrat
démocratique que le président la
république a passé avec la société
française à travers ses 150 citoyens
soient respectés
moi j'ai beaucoup d'inquiétude à ce
stade sur le respect de ce contrat très
bien et oui patrick halet renard
question passe car oui patrick adler
disait que ce ne serait pas un plan de
relance sociale pour le pouvoir d'achat
vous vous dites bon c'est plutôt sur le
côté climat oui enfin les deux ne se
pose pas donc les deux ne se pose pas et
vous sur le côté pouvoir d'achat sociale
vous trouvez que c'est un plan de
relance et libérale et de droite
moi je pense qu'effectivement
aujourd'hui on a un vrai souci dans la
société française
sur le fait que à part le tiers
supérieur de la société le reste de la
société souffre donc est-ce que derrière
ce plan il y a aussi des mesures
fiscales de justice sociale c'est à dire
qu'à un moment il faut une société plus
égalité en terme fiscal qui ment je ne
vois pas le président de la république
du tout aller dans ce sens là puisqu'ils
me dit bien qu'il ne touchera pas aux
prélèvements mais il pourrait ne pas
toucher aux prélèvements sur la masse
globale est touché aux prélèvements sur
le fait de rééquilibrer entre les riches
et les pauvres et les petites classes
moyennes qui souffrent beaucoup
aujourd'hui donc ça je crois que c'est
très très absente ce plan de relance qui
de ce côté là reste effectivement dans
l'orthodoxie libérale c'est évident
merci beaucoup merci